are you looking to turn your gardening
passion into profit well you're in the
right place in today's video I'm going
to share with you the top seven easiest
crops to grow for profit that anyone can
start even if you're a complete beginner
so grab your gardening gloves and let's
dig in hey everyone welcome back to
ibraim Momo if you're looking to dive
into the world of farming and want to
know which crops can bring in some
serious cash with minimal effort you're
in the right place today we're talking
about the easiest crops to grow for
profit let's get started first off let's
talk about why choosing the right crops
is crucial for
profitability some crops require a lot
of time effort and resources While
others can Thrive with just a little
care so let's explore some of the best
options our first crop is radishes these
little guys are not only super easy to
grow but they also have a quick
turnaround time you can Harvest them in
as little as 3 to four weeks
plus they're popular in salads and can
be sold at local markets just plant them
in well- drained soil and you're good to
go next up we have lettuce this leafy
green is a favorite among health
conscious consumers it grows quickly and
can be harvested multiple times if you
use the cutand come again method just
make sure to keep it well watered and
you'll have a steady supply to sell
herbs are another fantastic option basil
mint and cilantro are easy to grow and
can be sold fresh or dried they don't
require much space and you can even grow
them in pots if you're short on room
plus they're always in demand at farmers
markets and
restaurants moving on to green beans
these are not only delicious but also
very productive they can be grown
vertically saving space and they yield a
lot of produce just plant them after the
last frost and you'll be harvesting in
about 50 to 60 days they're perfect for
selling fresher canning making them a
versatile choice for
profit next on our list is
zucchini this summer squash is
incredibly easy to grow and produces a
high yield just a few plants can provide
you with more zucchini than you know
what to do with they thrive in warm
weather and can be sold at local markets
or even to restaurants looking for fresh
produce now let's talk about potatoes
they're a staple food and can be quite
profitable while they take a bit longer
to grow around 70 to 120 days they're
relatively low maintenance plus you can
sell them in various forms fresh baked
or even as specialty varieties like
fingerlings finally we have
sunflowers not only do they brighten up
your garden but they can also be a great
source of income you can sell the seeds
use them for oil production or even sell
the flowers themselves they're easy to
grow and attract pollinators which is a
bonus for your other
crops before we wrap up here are a few
quick tips for growing these crops
successfully one start small if you're
new to farming begin with a small plot
to manage your time and resources
effectively two research your Market
know what crops are in demand in your
area to maximize your profits three soil
Health invest in good soil and compost
to ensure your plants Thrive four
watering regular watering is key
especially for crops like lettuce and
herbs five
Pest Management keep an eye out for
pests and diseases and use organic
methods whenever possible and there you
have it the easiest crops to grow for
profit these crops not only require
minimal effort but can also yield great
returns if managed well if you found
this video helpful please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to ibraim Momo
for more tips on Farming and gardening
and don't forget to hit that
notification Bell so you never miss an
update I want to hear from you let me
know in the comments which crops you're
excited to try or if you have any
questions about starting your own garden
your feedback helps me create content
that you love thanks for watching and
happy growing see you in the next video